[Music]
past life regression therapy is for
anyone who believes in reincarnation
it's for anyone who believes in the
amazing healing power of the conscious
and subconscious mind let's make a
commitment today as you go on your past
life regression experience you're not
going to worry if it's fantasy
imagination metaphor or memory the best
way to do past life regression is to
write down your intention for having
this experience make sure it's an
intention that will make your life as a
son or daughter of the 21st century more
authentic more joyous and better for you
some intentions might be well to
discover why I have a pain or an illness
that no doctor can help me with maybe it
was a death wound from a past life maybe
you're having a journey with someone in
this life where there's a repeating
pattern of pain and you want to find out
if you traveled with that person in the
past perhaps you would like to discover
a solution and you're having a dilemma
right now and you want to see did you
have that dilemma in any past life what
did you do how did it turn out so you
can make a wiser decision in the here
and now I have with me today David and I
have sequoia both of you think about an
intention about why you want a past life
regression experience and how it might
serve you as a son and daughter of the
21st century it's always best if you
write it down that gets it anchored into
the subconscious now we're ready to
begin get into a very comfortable place
you can sit in a chair like you're
meditating or you can lathe
any place that you're most comfortable
keep your eyes open and pick one spot a
single dot high up on a wall or on the
ceiling now stare at it as you stare at
it you'll find that your eyes get very
very tired in your eyes begin to blink
on one of the blinks just go ahead and
allow your eyes to close with your eyes
closed you're going to feel some very
pleasant little fluttering right under
the lashes when you feel that breathe
the word deeper right in to the bottom
of your toes now draw all of your
attention to the soles of your feet and
breathe in your power work your power
work today is the work trust as you
breathe in the word trust into the soles
of your feet up into your ankles and
calves your calves and your knees your
knees and your thighs you can let all of
the muscles relax wonderfully totally
and completely and now imagine what it
would be like to trust your powerful
legs no longer to use those legs to run
away from anything but instead use those
powerful legs to journey forward towards
your goal of fulfilling your intention
of discovering for a better more joyful
life today now breathe the word trust
right into the pelvic floor and there
you can access intuition and wisdom now
breathe the word trust right into the
appetite you can trust your appetite
to only have an appetite for yummy
delicious nutritious foods that nurture
nourish and heal the body the mind and
the spirit breathe the word trust into
your heart and as you breathe the word
trust into your heart you can breathe it
in as a beautiful white and silver light
and you can let it light up
any dark areas where there's been
rejection loss sadness or even
disappointment and breathe in the word
trust like a beautiful bright white and
silver light for you can heal yourself
in the present by understanding the past
if there's anything you're holding on
your shoulders that no longer serves you
release it let the jaw relax and the
teeth part you can remember a yummy
delicious nutritious meal that you've
had recently remember what the food
looked like remember conversation around
you of you're watching a TV or even
BuzzFeed remember what the topic was or
you can even remember your own thoughts
remember what the food smelled like
and tasted like and what you felt like
eating it because you can remember now
once again breathe in your intention of
why you're having a past life regression
experience what you want to heal what
you want to learn what you want to
achieve what you want to release and
breathe in that intention for having
this experience today and now make an
image of what you may look like with
your eyes closed right now
ask your soul self to detach from your
body and let your soul self drift up
even higher higher looking down at your
body and let the soul self drift right
through the ceiling
so you can look down at all the rooftops
all around you in your mind's eye and
you can imagine or visualize picture
pretend or even just get a sense of what
all the rooftops look like below you now
drift up even higher even higher drift
up even higher so that you can see some
bodies of water and drift up even higher
so you can see the entire continent
where you live drift up even higher let
the soul self drift up even higher so
you can see our beautiful Bluegreen
planet like a marble spinning on its
axis below you with a cloud cover
and let the soul self drift up even
higher to a dimension beyond space and
time and in this dimension there is a
big tree floating there it's the Tree of
Life for all that hold fast to it and
let your soul self perch on top of that
tree and it's like nothing you've ever
experienced or even ever imagined and
you can look around to the infinite
horizons in every direction but now look
back down at the earth and use the power
of your mind to see the earth and in
your imagination picture pretend
visualize imagine or even get a sense
that you are so powerful you can slow
down the earth and then it stops and now
let the earth begin to rotate backwards
on its axis yes you are so powerful you
are reversing time and you can watch the
earth change the continents the waters
the ambient light the forests for we are
going back
in time and when you're ready again
breathe in your intention for having
your past life experience and you're not
gonna worry if it's fantasy imagination
metaphor or memory for you made that
commitment to honor they experience the
conscious and subconscious mind has for
you it's true and now as you remember
your intention the place in time that
answers your question is going to pull
the consciousness towards it like a
magnet and as I count from ten backwards
to zero let yourself get pulled towards
another place another time where you'll
be able to see through younger eyes here
through younger years the earth was a
younger earth and it will be imagination
visualization it might be like a memory
like a dream like a fantasy or like a
story told by an ancestor around the
fire long ago and here we go 10
nine eight seven six pulling in towards
the hemisphere the continent the time
the country the city the town the space
five four three two one zero
you are there look down at your feet or
even in your imagination like a memory
what are you wearing on your feet or are
you barefoot what are you holding in
your hand
what is covering your loins are you a
man or a woman a boy or a girl or are
you in a culture that's beyond gender
look around you at the vistas around you
orient yourself in space are there swaps
our villages desert ocean forests towns
[Music]
and orient yourself in Thai listen is
someone calling to you or do you know
your name and what place are you and
what time are you in this other place in
this other time and now breathe in your
intention for your past life regression
and let the soul self pull you towards
the event or events that will fulfill
your intention with five four three two
one zero
you are there
are you alone are there other people is
it safe for scary is it warm or cold
do you recognize anyone that you may
travel with as a son or daughter of the
21st century do you recognize anybody
else's soul for soul groups have a
tendency to travel together what is
happening how does it reveal the answer
to your question now it is very very
safe and very educational and very
revealing and very healing to find out
how you died in that past life so with
no emotion and no pain
let yourself travel
to the moment after you died in your
past life what was the death wound or
was it disease or natural causes
what part or parts of the bodies gave
out so that you went from this world to
the world to come and let your salsa
feel lighter and lighter light as a
feather lifting and rising lifting and
rising higher and higher up up up until
you arrived at the world to come where
you will reunite with every incarnation
from every life in the past but you will
also reunite with all the wisdom from
all the lives you will live in the
future when you see the next evolution
of humankind and now you have all that
information wisdom perspective and
insight you now can ask a question to
your wise self the compilation of all of
your lives past present and future
[Music]
but now ask this question why selves
what can I take from this experience to
make my life as a child of the 21st
century
more joyous more intentional more
authentic and better so that each and
every day I can be proud of myself and
listen very carefully for that answer it
might sound like a wise voice like the
daughter of the divine it might be a
feeling an insight a vision an idea or
just a knowing when you get that answer
to that question memorize it and now
breathe in that answer right into the
pelvic floor and make it a part of your
life and as you do that you're so
powerful you can use the power of your
mind to return to the tree of life and
that dimension beyond
time and space and you can perch up high
on the Tree of Life
for those who hold fast to it and you
can look down at the earth and use the
power of your mind to slow the earth and
let it stop and then begin to rotate it
back again going in the proper direction
so that time is moving forward again and
when you do that begin to allow yourself
to descend looking at our beautiful blue
green marble our home our mother earth
coming down
seeing your hemisphere where you live
your continent coming down seeing your
county your city wherever you're doing
your past life regression and come right
through the roof and see your body there
with your eyes closed
and with your next breath come into your
physical body and as I count from one up
to five you will awaken refreshed alert
feeling so much better and you will
remember who you were in your past life
in everything you experienced as you
think about it more and more and more
details will come up into the conscious
mind you will remember that wonderful
gift which was the answer to your
question from your Y self about how can
I use this experience to make the here
and now more powerful more authentic
more joyous so that I can be proud
of Who I am and always make wise
decisions for me so that I can honor my
highest intention for myself my family
and everyone who I have the privilege to
meet one to slowly calmly three is that
nice deep breath feeling the breath in
the body four is a very alert number and
five is eyes open wide awake now when
you're ready pick up your book and write
down the answers to the question write
down in what way this experience
revealed the answers to your intention
and in what way you're gonna make
positive choices in your life because
you know what you're too good to hang
out in your comfort zone and you want
more out of life and you're not gonna
settle for Less because you know now
there's only one direction and that
direction is forward I hope you enjoyed
your past life regression enjoy the rest
of your day
[Laughter]
hey unsolved is on a new channel and now
you're part subscribe here that was my
part